-George Lopez!
-Gracias!
-It is always great to see you,
my friend.
-Yeah.
-You're such a funny, funny man.
You were showing me something
backstage, by the way.
-Yeah.
-Can we talk about it here?
Something very --
very cool thing.
This is --
-This --
[ Audience oohs ]
-Look at that.
Yeah, show it off.
That's gorgeous.
-This Rolex...
-Yeah.
...belonged to
the great Johnny Carson.
This is Johnny Carson's.
-Let me see this thing.
How did you --
-There was a jeweler
in Hollywood,
and it came into his possession,
and they thought,
"Well, you know, I think I might
know a guy that is interested."
You know, I love comedy.
I love the history of comedy.
-Of course.
-"The Tonight Show" --
I watched "The Tonight Show"
with Freddie Prinze,
Richard Pryor,
all my idols growing up.
-Yeah.
-And then, now you.
It was only right that the watch
come back to New York
and pay its dues right here
on "The Tonight Show."
-Come on, Johnny.
-Johnny.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What year was that
when you were on with Johnny?
Do you remember?
-Man, you know what's crazy is,
it was -- it was November
of '91.
-Is that right?
-So, then I'm 30 years old,
and then I'm behind this curtain
here now,
and I'm 61 years old.
-Good for you, bud. Right?
-And, man, I made it back.
So, yeah.
-[ Laughs ] Exactly.
-I made it back!
-No, you're alwa--
-Even though I look like --
even though I look like a
Mariachi and a wolf had a baby.
-No, no, no, you do --
[ Laughter ]
-You know what's crazy?
Before, when I left the hotel,
they're like,
"Hey, good luck on your show
Friday, Cheech."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-"All right."
-Cheech. I'll take --
I'll take it.
But, no, you always crush.
I remember seeing you
at The Improv and Laugh Factory
out in L.A. and, honestly,
you would never want to follow
George Lopez, because you --
the audience would
give you standing ovations
during the middle of your act.
-They were all, you know,
Latinos.
-No, no, no.
You crushed it every single time
I saw you, everywhere.
You're always great.
-Oh, thank you, man.
-And you're nice to me, too.
I'll never forget that.
-Absolutely.
You're a great guy.
-Thank you. Let's talk about
your new series,
"Lopez vs. Lopez."
Your co-star
is your real-life daughter.
-My daughter, Mayan.
26 years old.
-Mayan Lopez --
-I was divorced.
And, then, you know, Mayan and
I didn't talk for a long time.
And she went on TikTok
to respond to a video
that someone made
attacking me.
And it was a video of her
twerking upside down.
-Hm.
-And then, you know, I mean,
I realized I wasn't
the best dad,
but when your kid's twerking
upside down,
you've got some real [bleep]
problems.
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "I didn't realize
it was this serious."
-Yeah, you got to --
you got to start -- yeah.
Yeah, wow, wow.
No, I understand.
No, I get -- yeah, I got it.
All right, well --
-I better get out there.
I got to get out there.
-Yeah, I've got to get out there
and start.
But you said you said you've
been through therapy now
with your daughter.
-Yeah.
The therapy -- yeah, of course.
You know, because, you know,
you have to be responsible
for the trauma
that you've caused.
-Yeah.
Where my grandmother would have
been like -- yeah, hey, right?
So, I -- I'm owning, for
the first time in my life,
my responsibility that --
to the marriage and as a father,
and, you know, as a -- you know,
to my daughter that I --
for the first time in my life,
I said, "Yeah, I'm responsible
for this, and I'm going to spend
the rest of my life
repairing it."
-Good for you.
-And hopefully we can do it --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good for you.
-For seven years on NBC.
[ Laughter ]
-You didn't know it was
going to be a TV show.
-And then nobody will ever
see me again.
No.
-[ Laughs ]
-No, but -- but, you know,
if you think therapy is bad,
what's worse is
the elevator ride down after.
[ Laughter ]
Because it's all heavy stuff,
and then you're just
in the elevator --
You almost have to stagger out,
like when you dine and dash,
somebody goes out the back,
somebody goes out the front.
-[ Laughs ] So, yeah, yeah.
Just leave right now.
Yeah, we're in --
-Don't go in the same car --
-No.
-When you're doing
trauma therapy.
And somebody just leaves
out the back,
and the other person's
just out the front --
-Yeah. Can we describe the show
any more than we have?
I mean, it's you
and your daughter.
-Yeah, me and my daughter.
And working it out.
Yeah. And, you know, the --
I live with them,
because after the pandemic,
you know,
I might have lost my business.
So, it deals with --
the beginning of the episode
is where I start
to live with them.
And that's why I look like this,
because there's only --
you can only go up from this.
-[ Laughs ] No, come on.
But it's generational.
It's also --
-It's generational.
And everybody will love it.
And whether you have issues or
not, it's just really funny.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. And that's what we need
right now.
-Absolutely.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's George Lopez
in "Lopez vs. Lopez."
Take a look at this.
-I'm still not calling you
Chance,
because looks like there's a
chance that's not your father.
[ Laughter ]
-Why would you say
something like that?
-Because the kid looks
very Mexican,
and you look like somebody
that wouldn't get a rose
on "The Bachelorette."
[ Laughter ]
-Look, George, even though I'm
not the toxic Alpha male
you wanted for Mayan's
life partner, I am confident
in who I am,
so you can't hurt me.
-Yeah, you broke eye contact
at the end there, bro.
[ Laughter ]
-Dammit.
-That's exactly right.
George Lopez, everybody.
"Lopez vs. Lopez" premieres
this Friday at 8:00 p.m.
on NBC.
Cole Hauser joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody!
Johnny!